hey what's up guys it's marcus brownlee
here from mkbhd and today we're going to
be taking a look at a piece of freeware
that will allow you to stream your face
your pictures some media and a number of
other picture-in-picture media related
items all on the popular ustream.tv so
let's just go ahead and take a look
so the name of the application itself is
called ustream producer and it's a
desktop application that'll allow you to
share your media whether you're running
windows or os 10 in a very professional
clean and quite smooth manner some of
you guys may have noticed i've been
streaming on ustream.tv a little bit
more than usual and i've been announcing
it on twitter.commkbhd
but i'm going to give you guys a
walkthrough of the feature set that i
found while i was testing the software
during these live streams
you've probably noticed by now that
there is a free version and a pro
version a 200 piece of software for a
one-time fee but you'll notice there are
a lot of nice features that i think are
really appealing to a professional and i
might definitely consider this in the
future but probably not now
so once you've actually acquired the
ustream producer software for your
specific operating system you'll be able
to go right ahead and launch it for the
first time and it'll ask you for your
ustream credentials after the splash
screen go ahead and enter your username
and your password and you're all set to
go
natively within the application itself
you'll see your your very familiar
windows buttons for file and for edit
and then you'll see also some native
ustream producer application buttons
like the broadcast button and the window
button and these will help you customize
your stream and set up settings before
you actually broadcast live
i think it's also noteworthy that under
the upgrade tab you can choose to try
out the new features of ustream producer
pro the 200 desktop application just to
see if it's worth buying or if you
actually don't need it
what's unique and also very special
about this producer application is this
bar in the middle which allows you to
manipulate the media you're streaming
live such as the live video feed and
also some screencast as well as some
pictures maybe some sound you want to
input and you can also use a little bit
of picture and picture effects too
what's also cool about this app is your
ability to change things on the fly so
what's cool is that you can change
what's picture in picture and which
images and videos you're showing on the
screen that correspond with which audio
during the live stream which is very
cool and tends to impress your viewers
if you're going for a more professional
look
another nice part of this application is
the simplicity of the settings bar which
allows you to change settings of the
application quickly and easily so if you
have a high quality or even a high
definition camera that connects by a
firewire or usb you can stream in high
frame rates using this camcorder and
it'll look very very good
this client also happens to have some
share features so you can let more
people know your broadcasting and end up
talking to more people this has connect
via facebook and via twitter and more so
you can go ahead and tweet out when you
begin your stream automatically using
this ustream client
overall this was a really nice
application to play with and i'm so glad
that i found it and it's going to
definitely encourage me to stream live
on ustream.tv a little bit more often
and probably most often during weekends
so if you want to be the first updated
when i do actually stream you can follow
me on twitter.commkbhd
and you'll be the first to know when i
do go live so thanks for watching mkbhd
signing out peace